wie man eine erfolgreiche ehe führt man
muss sich manchmal einfach taub stellen
dieser tipp stammt von rolf bader
ginsburg jan in diesem kleinen
humorvollen satz sieht man die ganze
intelligenz einer ganz besonderen frau
die jetzt im alter von 87 jahren
verstorben ist
ginsberg war richterin am obersten
gerichtshof der usa sie waren noch viel
mehr als dass sie setzte sich für
frauenrechte und gleichstellung ein wie
keine andere
sie traute sich zu widersprechen id cent
ich widerspreche so das motto dieser
zierlichen eleganten frau die jura zu
einer zeit studierte als es für frauen
kaum andere wege als den zum herz gab
ihr tod stürzt das linksliberale amerika
in trauer und auf der anderen seite gibt
es us-präsident trump die chance das
land auf jahrzehnte konservativ zu
prägen denn er kann die nachfolge des
buchs im supreme court ernennen eine
stelle auf lebenszeit ja und wie das das
klima der usa verändern könnte darüber
möchte ich jetzt mit unserem
korrespondenten herbert bauernebel
sprechen
herbert welche folgen könnte diese
neubesetzung des supreme courts diese
eine position für die usa haben das
ganze ist natürlich ein unglaubliches
politisches drama amerika kann fast
nicht glauben dass in diese explosive
stimmung die in amerika ohnehin herrscht
jetzt eben die die nachricht vom tod der
höchsten richterin ruth bader ginsburg
geplatzt ist es folgt jetzt natürlich
einer wahrscheinlich die mutter aller
politischen schlachten um die
nominierung der des nachfolgers oder
einer nachfolgerin einer der höchst
richterin um das spaltet amerika
natürlich noch weiter es wird erwartet
dass us präsidenten bereits in den
nächsten tagen eine einen kandidaten
oder eine kandidatin vorstellen wird als
nix als nominierte für den supreme court
es wird gerechnet
das ist möglicherweise eine konservative
frau eine rechnerin sein wird dann lande
dann wandert dieser diese schlacht diese
politische schlacht in den kongress
natürlich besonders in den senat deshalb
muss das dann bestätigen und genau diese
schlacht im senat wird jetzt hinein
nach mitten in den wahlkampf ziehen
allerdings nicht gerechnet das ist vor
dem wahltag am dritten november noch
eine entscheidung geben wird es wird
gerechnet damit dass es danach im
november im dezember möglicherweise ein
hearing eine eine bestätigung geben
könnte die demokraten werden das
natürlich bekämpfen so gut es geht sie
sagen es soll gewartet werden auf den
ausgang der wahlen soll darauf gewartet
werden dass er neuer präsident die
demokraten auf natürlich auch joe biden
ein ziel ins oval office und erst dann
eine entscheidung getroffen wird
die nachfolger der ein konservativer
nachfolger würde den supreme court
wirklich unter mental ändern es wäre ein
ganz konservative supreme court dann mit
einer mehrheit von 623 für die
republikaner
und das natürlich nicht beeinflusst die
amerikanische politik möglicherweise auf
jahrzehnte
ja richterin am supreme court eine
stelle auf lebenszeit herbert bauernebel
vielen herzlichen dank
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren